you want your friends to rise in whatever
ranks it is but there's a degree of their
rise where they're like [ __ ] that guy everyone
does that it's just it's uh it's hard to get
away from i don't know for some reason i want
to pull you down yes they're crabs in a bucket
yeah yeah i mean at some point well and then
society
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're listening
to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
you know george is oh i'm sure he's around
here somewhere what's his name george lopez
george lopez oh my god omg omg hi oh my god
your voicemail would you send us
so there's a couple of them let's see which
ones are the best ones oh [ __ ] the one you
did on the phone when you left so jack nicholson
and joe press you go to the laker game back
in the in the 2000s and uh they're sitting
there the big deal because jack's always there
joe has his hat he's sitting there like that
you know and then when they go to uh after
the game they go home to jack nicholson's
house press you met him there and they go
inside and uh and uh jack nicholson goes i'm
gonna have to ask you to leave and he goes
why you [ __ ] and he goes because i have
a young lady coming over and i to go upstairs
and make myself presentable and uh joe fashion
she goes why are you [ __ ] she's not coming
over here to [ __ ] you she's coming over
here to [ __ ] jack nicholson you don't care
about [ __ ] what you look like how you smell
what the [ __ ] you're wearing and jackos
nonetheless and then he goes hey jack you
ever use viagra and he goes only when i'm
outnumbered
he's got [ __ ] all over his nose his shirt's
all white and he's so on a saturday afternoon
about four o'clock 4 15 i'm on the 10th 11th
12th 13th hole the one that goes uphill yeah
yeah back yeah i went through the tree there
and and i'm in the middle there that [ __
] ball comes flying over my head and there's
nobody out there right you know it's a late
afternoon nobody goes out there and in a no
top like the ones i use i look over and jack
has a shirt that's like stuck to him because
of all his sweat yeah i just stuck to him
[ __ ] coke dust right here [ __ ] coke rings
hair back like wet back and he and he goes
we're going to play through george i said
yeah
yeah i said hey go ahead yeah go go go go
and then i went down to look how far they
were [ __ ] gone these [ __ ] went i said
like in greece they just [ __ ] took off kept
going yeah but dave jack was a [ __ ] trip
because he wasn't that good and he never played
18 in a row well he just bounced around pesch
does that now like pesh kind of just will
do like you know three here two there yeah
and then circle back sometimes sometimes i'll
see him sitting in the sand trap for like
15 minutes just messing up so so i remember
this one so junior the sky junior but like
25 years ago i think he's been there that
long and uh it was his first week and jack
nicholson goes in and he's smoking a cigarette
in the pro shop and junior's like [ __ ] do
i say i mean you know he goes hey mr nicholson
um you can't smoke in the pro shop or what
yeah yeah he's like uh oh or you know the
police he goes i'll take my chance right yeah
and then the next the next afternoon who walks
through the [ __ ] pro shop with you [ __
] pesci you spoke with a cigarette brother
i heard you can't smoke it this [ __ ]
or what what will happen nothing hey i heard
you can't smoke in this [ __ ] [ __ ] flowers
you've seen that clip of chappelle when he
first came back and he was in a like i think
he was at the comedy store in london you know
the london comedy store which has no affiliation
to ours but there's like a real low ceiling
and his eyes are kind of you can't really
see much you know like the the spot is really
bright and some guy in the back is is yelling
he's like you can't smoke you can't smoke
and he's like what he's like you you can't
smoke she was like no [ __ ] you can't smoke
in here like nothing ever happened it was
great i mean the crowd went ape [ __ ] i [ __
] lost it it's true some people can smoke
inside some people can smell he smokes he
smokes inside everywhere he still comes to
the common store and smokes inside who's going
to do like two hours the last time i saw him
at the club it was maybe two and some change
i used to [ __ ] do two hours i couldn't beg
for my [ __ ] life for two hours yeah i'd
be like you know [ __ ] just kill me man 45
50 minutes maybe not two hours nuts two hours
forget i would do two and i would do two an
hour 45 yeah [ __ ] and then and big places
they would be like uh what are you gonna do
man i said you know set the clock at hour
45 or an hour 30 yeah then i'll get off at
hour 45. i did a [ __ ] live hbo special 85
minutes that's so much i couldn't do it again
that's so much to do for a special because
for a special your energy is through the roof
you're doing so much more than you need to
do when you do a special because your mind
is racing like you're overthinking all of
the bits making sure that every all the puzzle
pieces when you're doing a live show show
i go long on shows just if you're having fun
right but in a special mindset your brain
is like i need to knock out these things and
they told me you have to be done between 85
and 90 or else guess what happens i go what
they [ __ ] cut go to [ __ ] yeah they cut
somewhere baker with a rubber red for him
but it's a lot i i i did them live because
i thought how can you make stand-up like more
risky yeah and i said you know how you can
you do a special live yeah it is where i don't
think you could do it now because [ __ ] would
be in there trying to [ __ ] with you yeah
also there's no respect yeah with the internet
now yeah so it's just the game is different
on where specials go so live was like it was
a must-see event like people had to go watch
it now the internet is like i'll see it whenever
i'm ready i know yeah it's up to the audience
now which is kind of i mean it's good but
you have almost no control on programming
when somebody's like it comes out wednesday
and people are like no it doesn't comes out
whenever i watch it that's right you know
in people's mind they're like it comes out
when i need to say and then they look at ratings
like uh three and seven days or 14 days where
before it was solely like when my show started
just on tv there was streaming there wasn't
uh you know even that was the beginning of
of um reality tv yeah that's why you know
i i i don't know maybe just me because i'm
not in the business at all but it seems that
all the good specials yeah but you're dressed
like you're in the busy
they uh all the good they're taking their
skin both i love that they're [ __ ] virgins
all the good the the big comedians you know
they did the special they started coming out
and everybody wanted to watch them now it
just seems like they have maybe i'm getting
older they have more more specials it's like
when you order this with less known companies
would you like to try our specials today what
are they fried chicken and a hamburger they're
[ __ ] special every day wow i mean you know
they're not special they're not special and
the comedians are using are not that i don't
say they're not that good they're just not
that's what he's saying that's what he's saying
hey i'm not the one that got shot at by one
of his old men all right so last week
it was a chip it was a chippy i don't remember
the dude didn't shoot you when you had pulled
a gun on the ground officers [ __ ] that was
years ago yeah yeah yeah yeah you know he
caught the nightstalker right wait who did
yeah you did so gil was a sheriff you uh for
so he go through the whole thing no we're
not pretty good so so he was he was on the
streets and up in east l.a in that area up
there hussein heights and and a cop said hey
man did you to your parents and never and
said this kid either gets off the street or
he's going to end up dead and they're going
to go [ __ ] somewhere and he went to bed
and he [ __ ] went to vietnam yeah 17 they
signed me aside from me get off the streets
you're gonna in a prison day vietnam and so
then i i ended up in vietnam come back and
things turned around and it was all good it's
been a good life since i remember how long
were you in vietnam i was there for a year
is that was that what a tour was a year tour
was a year and those chicken chips in the
army they sent me back on emergency leave
you know in january my grandmother passed
away and my grandmother passed away and my
sister was a good liar on her feet because
they went and they told the red cross hey
can you let him know his red cross and she
said they said yes but you understand unless
the grandmother had raised him that won't
allow him to come back for the funeral and
she said that's the only reason i'm here telling
you because she did raise it well my grandma
never raised me and so they sent word back
to my unit my unit then says okay and that's
all you needed was word back then you didn't
need to say yeah now you need a death certificate
yeah no they just said hey we got this news
for you your grandmother died and we've just
been we had had the [ __ ] shot out of us
the night before we're going back to pick
up parts and they said hey come in here the
first pig wants to talk to hey do you know
julia castro i said yes they said well we're
here sorry
i'm just telling my family from the time i
was 11 years old yeah i don't know how how
we started doing this but if somebody was
talking about a girl i would say does he have
big titties yeah but this is probably 60 years
by the time i was 11. and they would pull
me out of the cloud they'd get me like this
outside i heard you outside the real question
yeah he's got me saying it now and if i don't
do it it's going to end the longest streak
that i think other than that but but i mean
so they sent me home that's what i yeah they
tell you she was there they they said you
can you want to go home and i'm saying i'm
biting myself on the cheek with the inside
yes yeah yeah so they sent me home and they
said we've got your personnel files right
here we pulled them all out because you've
only got another month left in country probably
won't send you back to finish that one month
in country so they send me back with all my
all my papers i went back i remember my mom
cried she found my she found my personal jacket
because it was in with my dirty clothes she
could wash my clothes she found she started
reading them and she didn't realize i had
lied to everybody back here they never knew
i was in combat you know what i was doing
and now they've got the stuff they're reading
their medals and yeah and so now you know
i said mom it's okay i don't have to go back
i'm done they're not gonna send me back then
i get this [ __ ] letter it says ah no you
to go back they made me go back for another
month that made you do the whole 12 months
they made me do the whole 12 months i sent
me back to vietnam give me another month i
was due to come back february i got there
first week of february 1968 right at the beginning
of 10 offensive so i'm doing it come back
the first week of february and instead they
held me there until march you know what man
i don't know what i would do i mean i love
this country but but i'm not sure what i would
do like i'm not made for
he doesn't want to admit it he's a reserve
he's a national guard yeah i'm i'm still in
rotc i think i'm i'm just in there but was
it was kind of like the the minor leagues
for for the military yeah yeah they get you
into school farm league yeah and you're marching
on the football field and [ __ ] while everybody's
out there talking to chicks at lunch yeah
my buddy did that was my first roommate in
college he was rotc and got kicked out got
kicked out of school and the rotc which is
hard to do because the rotc needs your ass
to stay they need people better you do never
showed up showed up drunk if he did show up
was drunk and never showed up so he'd have
his you know he'd have superior yelling at
him come come and get him out of his dorm
room he i mean his whole life was needed structure
so it was good but it never worked for this
dude because nothing was gonna fix him he
was on his own little planet so so so guys
that are on their own little planet and then
they go to the military and they got long
hair and they cut their hair and then they
kind of deprogrammed you right where you laughed
and the guy [ __ ] kicked you in your ass
you were laughing at him and he's like what
the [ __ ] are you laughing at yeah yeah and
so they're breaking you down and then you
become we all become the same we all yeah
you know and then all the same they give you
you think the same they i don't know propaganda
what they do to you but all of a sudden it's
the army way and you got to do it that way
you know you believe in it you believe and
it's not till after i came back that i was
in germany and i said you know war is hell
there are no winners in war nobody wins either
side nobody wins everybody has people dying
everybody has family people that love them
and yet we go over there and we do this because
they're asking us to you know and and you
don't think twice about it when you're in
the middle of it man all you can think about
hey we've got to take care of business you
know you're guarding your partner you're guarding
you you want to stay alive you're fighting
to stay alive how often were you scared were
you scared ever
can you forget that you're in vietnam no by
just doing your job i don't think i don't
think you could no yeah because when you every
day you look out yeah it's there it's there
i had an old pilot uh that had seen me on
television doing police work here through
the department he got in touch with me and
he said i had to talk to you he says weren't
you weren't you ever afraid because all you
did was laugh he says that's all you ever
did here and i was a crew chief on a helicopter
so essentially when you're up there flying
you're shooting a gun that's all you're doing
and he says and we've been through some heavy
stuff and i said you know mr johnson i can
still hear you saying oh my god oh my god
oh my god he's in a hover hole
oh my god oh my god i can hear you saying
oh my god oh my god oh my god he says and
all i can hear you is laughing saying it's
okay mr johnson they're just throwing softballs
at us you just keep flying you're doing good
you know and and he got us out of it and i
owe the guy my life you know he's the one
that got us up and out of it we're taking
all this [ __ ] those were before black hawk
those were just those were just i know those
are those are like the the the hyundai's yeah
the sky yeah well they didn't even bring them
back that after aircraft carrier they ditched
them in the water yeah they got rid of it
they threw them in the water and i think that's
too stupid to be afraid you know and i not
sit there after you you're going hot then
you you're breaking away because you're gonna
come back and make another and you're saying
oh dear god just let me get through this one
come on you know please god help me out you
know you get through it on the way back and
but once you were away from it you're all
good it doesn't matter just like walking down
the block again well a bunch of young kids
is all i can ever think about it's like are
you sneaking away trying to see girls ever
over there or yeah over there no never no
no you're gonna leave though well no i take
that back yes i was gonna say so it's about
a 19 year old boy oh yeah you go into town
and it was restricted because it was a heavy
fortified vc bait you know where we were at
a lot of so you're allowed to go into open
storefronts if there were stores you weren't
allowed to go off the street and really if
you had the time and i didn't get to go into
town that often but when you did you couldn't
wait to get off the streets right you know
just go catch a little you know bang bang
yeah
uh good morning vietnam uh robin williams
yeah the way the kids steal [ __ ] that's
just the way they were you know and i didn't
realize that you know you think the little
pieces of [ __ ] well they're they're doing
what they got to do to get by so we'd go buy
it and get boxes of c rations and put what
was in those oh c rash were canned meats ham
and eggs meatloaf bone chicken uh there were
vegetables in them some of that [ __ ] was
good as i said i guess some of it's got to
be all right yeah i trade around i love the
ham and eggs and it so it's in like a tin
and you open it and you heat it or you just
open it good if you had time to heat it you'd
eat it sometimes you didn't and you had these
little uh p-38s they're a little can opener
just a little small thing around a little
key like yeah open it up eat your stuff so
you take a case of them in a case there was
12 boxes of sea rations and so you'd leave
the box in the back of the jeep or the back
of the truck so they could see that it was
there knowing that they're going to steal
it oh yeah as i could just take it yeah firearms
no you put a smoke grenade in there that's
awesome yeah open the box that's like when
you're going to rob a bank of them you go
look at everybody pam yeah right [ __ ] dialogue
put smoke on them or give them uh they love
candy so xlax your mix likes your different
it's a different world you know when you're
doing that stuff yeah and just watch and they
run around they'd run fast they're no way
this fat ass ever gonna get i was thin then
but i'm not gonna chase anybody so they'd
run and then you hear and then you can see
the smoke coming up and then yeah and then
you'd see them run around you know about that
new number 10 gi you know and then you know
pumping you off but didn't hurt anybody it
was just just for fun yeah how old were you
how old were you i was 18. i just turned 18.
18. i turned 18 november 29th and i was there
the first week of february what did you do
on your 18th birthday do you remember
on the actual day of like you were probably
still in high school right yeah i was a senior
in high school you remember granted i haven't
remember what did you do i went to buffalo
wild wings and that sounds about right sure
maybe we went to hooters i'm almost positive
we went to hooters my buddy's dad i mean i
was interested i was in uh chicken wings i
was in fort stewart georgia i was in the army
by myself you know what i did huh i went with
the guys i was playing baseball with april
23rd the day of my 18th birthday went to hollywood
boulevard to the pussycat theater and we watched
deep throat and the devil in his jones [ __
] cochinole still in high school man my heroes
and then we had the first baseman eddie rico's
big dude and he would laugh like and when
they were [ __ ] he would just be laughing
like hey shut the [ __ ] up you've never seen
i don't know no i've never seen a porno how
was deep throat it's like the iconic one but
i don't know how many people actually see
it it's a good movie tons of people saw that
right it happened it was on hollywood boulevard
yeah that kind of [ __ ] soundtrack by the
way
i got to give the other side of it okay so
i messed with the kids nothing serious never
hurt anybody were you gonna go and get some
americans what i did helped start an orphanage
over there and i wrote back the city that
i grew up in peace what do you mean you left
all the kids in one [ __ ] little house yeah
no no they were finished they were living
my heart when we saw these little kids it's
awful eight eight years old teaching them
how to protect their village you know with
oozies and any gun that they can get their
hands on so then the guys that i was flying
with everybody just took it upon themselves
wrote home i wrote home to my family of pico
they put it in the local pico press here on
the pickle paper and asking for help so i
got clothes and stuff sent to me we helped
start a village a little orphanage back there
the orphanage is still in existence today
wow they're still supported by the same guys
that uh same kids are there they're [ __ ] 75
years old yeah yeah yeah they never got out
of the way one of the kids was a little girl
that is now uh married alive and well living
in honeymoon and uh probably long nipples
but not nothing yeah yeah happy heavy long
nipples she uh she's wanted to thank people
you know because she made it out you know
she was part of the orphanage and she's here
now she's wild that's insane do you ever go
in the middle of the night and scare her hey
so so um i don't know man i just don't i you
know it's fine i'm not fascinated by by asking
you because i know i know that i i'm not sure
there were no like um ied like another stuff
like they had in afghanistan where you're
walking and you blow up no and and i didn't
worry about that i you know they didn't booby
trap back they had mine back then i was up
and i was up in helicopter you know so land
to get back to my hooch and the only time
i was ever in the vehicle was when we had
to go pick up more ammunition or go make a
trash would you take food to the guys pick
up trash like get down low dump all the [ __
] maybe take a guy with you and get the [ __
] out of there like fly in and fly out no
no no i'm take that's the only time i was
in a vehicle in a helicopter two kinds i was
there number one for the first seven months
i was in what we call slicks these are huey
helicopters that would go in we would resupply
take them either food their mail ammunition
new troops we would extract old troops wounded
troops dead troops so insertion extraction
that's what we did at one time we were flying
uh defoliation you know this agent orange
that you hear about they put a big [ __ ] bladder
inside the helicopter oh my god sprayers out
there no and then we'd ride fly over rice
paddies matter of fact that's the only time
i ever saw
somebody that i ever shot because when you
people are shooting at you you're shooting
back all you're seeing is muzzle flashes well
now i'm flying over a rice paddy right by
the end of these dikes that are in between
them as we're going all of us and you're flying
slow you're low and slow and all of a sudden
some little ding jumps up hit the helicopter
at least three or four times before i reacted
and i hit him and when i hit him and he flew
bam he flipped and fell and went back down
and as soon as that happens you immediately
have to drop smoke to mark the spot and then
you pull up and out and then the gun ships
that are flying escort for you they come in
with mini guns and rockets and so that day
i just made a decision man i'm tired of running
every time you get shot you got to run the
gun big boys with the guns come in so i went
and i said i want to fly guns so i went to
gunships and never saw another vietnamese
soldier or anybody south vietnamese vc north
vietnamese that i hit but then i did that's
the only one i ever saw country the rest of
time is all gunships so there's a reason for
tracer fire so they can see where they're
where they're shooting yeah you want to say
something you can my memory served me correctly
it's every fifth or every tenth round as a
tracer oh i didn't know that yeah so you so
the other guys would come in after you guys
to clean up huh they would we didn't go in
to clean up nobody went in to clean up you
did what you had to do and then finish up
if there was would they go in to make sure
there was no other soldiers there is that
why they were backing up no why would they
come in after you guys then when you put the
gun chips as soon as you'd mark the spot where
it happened yeah first thing you do is you
you know incoming or shots fired and then
i would throw one there'd be another slick
behind me he was gonna so they the gunships
we would then pull out the gunships in okay
somewhere between the two smokes that's where
the enemy was just so they just come in with
miniguns and rockets what was the caliber
what were you shooting i was using m60 7.62
rounds and the m16 was uh 5.62 and it was
every five rounds for tracers yeah and what's
overstepple the thing yeah and they said with
that 50 caliber gun with a sniper even if
it misses somebody if it goes by them it'll
sear their skin oh yeah that's going so fast
50 calibers is snuggly big vicious weapon
you know we could never shoot something like
that you know with what we had that's a big
isn't it it's huge isn't it big massive yeah
you see you see them you can't believe they
go they go in and come out of a [ __ ] gun
that's so big those guys i did the harry truman
out there in the ocean a couple years ago
and i shot the 50 caliber and you're not even
looking you know the ship the gun is out there
but you're in here looking at a screen and
you have the red thing and you look and you'll
say fire and you just shoot into the thing
but i go what do you see out here goes ah
those guys are like oh man we see some somali
pirates and they try to come at us and like
what are you guys to go he goes jordan they
they disappear like in a puff of bread like
[ __ ] they just they're gone yeah they disintegrate
and they don't give a [ __ ] they brother
bullets yeah they ride up on us and he goes
they ride up on us and these dinky ass [ __
] things and they start shooting like you're
pop pop and they're like are they [ __ ] shooting
those guys have balls man they run up on the
biggest ships yeah they do we had uh we went
you hear that somali pirates you guys are
gonna have shoes they don't run it up on our
boats flying guns they gave us a mission it
was to search and destroy pack elephants the
north vietnamese and south koreans were using
elephants to transport their food and ammunition
their weapons so they said okay here's where
they're last seen there's a group go out there
so we go out we shoot elephants shoot elephants
and we went out and what we did was we had
white phosphorus willie peter in the rockets
so you'd go in here light it up this way light
it up this way make another run and light
it up that way so the only way the elements
can get out is oh my god you'd pull them out
yeah and they'd say okay here they go here
they come you guys get them first so they
allowed us and we had free wheeling 60s you
guys get them and and remember this is so
so there's smoke there's there's smoke here
and they're looking they see smoke and they
don't see smoke there so they're running they're
running out right towards you towards towards
the open door and this is i think that's better
than the circus huh yeah this is not for bottom
belly take notes man remember this is war
you know and it's not something that i would
ever do or think of or yeah no no don't don't
write me letters animal activists but they're
coming out and then the fighters thought okay
you guys get first crack so we're shooting
our free wheeling 60s at them and you hit
them and a 60 on that elevator just like flies
you know yeah he's going to say that that
can't hurt him that much that involved he
said okay your turns up now our turn then
they'd come in and they'd hit them with rockets
but all that ever happened with rockets is
they they hit right below and the elephant
just you just see the elephant just go boom
fall over yeah fall over sideways dead dead
like shocked hit i don't know what the [ __
] is we're gonna go down we weren't gonna
go down with the stethoscope yeah yeah we'll
just take its pulse see how it is there's
no heads they go for the legs though that's
all nobody's calling code blue well with rockets
you're just shooting at it yeah you're aiming
at anything close and back then the the sights
for rockets weren't that really this was the
site for the rock this was the site and what
you would do is they put a little circle with
an x on the on the windshield oh my god okay
yeah yeah they would just move it if it was
off right now you put that sticker over here
you name it you name it uh over there so you
have to be more of a marksman than than i
would say now maybe yeah you'd have to shoot
it okay let's see where that okay now let's
try it again uh i'm even i'm like googling
this as you're talking about it i'm not even
finding a lot of results about people talking
about shooting elephants yeah and the v like
i'm sure they didn't brag about it but like
i'm sure that was breaking news i'm sure that
was military i'm sure that was military secrets
i mean that was like you know talk about nothing
i mean and it's and i emphasized that was
war not something that should be done you
know you talk about it was ugly there are
no winners in war did you ever have to hand
to hand somebody no no street fight no no
no no you think it was safer in the air than
it was on the ground oh i do you actually
feel that right that's what my first thought
was because i think just the opposite they
were scared to death of being in the air and
this fat ass didn't want to be in the jungle
with scorpions i'm with you put me in the
sky i'd come home you know i'd land re-arm
refuel and then go back to my hooch where
i had a cotton had a you know so you'd be
away yeah but then also there'd be guys behind
you bigger bigger bigger helicopters behind
you or in the slicks yeah you always had gunship
escorts you know you always had these gunships
escorting with you and when you're in gun
ships you know [ __ ] follow you you're just
gunnies you're not going to be you're not
going to be going down and landing you're
just going to be flying and shooting and coming
back home how many of those things just fell
on the uh just malfunctioned and crashed on
their own did that happen a lot or no uh no
it's not either pilot error they got shut
down they don't fall down their own so you
could they could shoot at you and penetrate
the the gas oh [ __ ] yeah so the helicopter
is just thin you know yeah it wouldn't [ __
] that i guess that's what i mean is like
those things must have been i mean no one's
checking them down every time you take them
off right you're just going are the mechanics
there wasn't much yeah yeah yeah we we're
no we're checking them oh you are yeah every
day the crew chief that was my job i'd get
out there and check the helicopter out make
sure that it's all it's flyable right i'm
gonna get in it it's gonna be flyable right
and you get it up you get in the air if it
took rounds well then you come back and now
they got to patch those rounds up and they
got to make sure we didn't hit anything there's
a few spots you know you if you lose an engine
you can still go down you just got to find
a place to land it uh you lose your tail rotor
you're done unless you got a long runway to
go to your your toast you know the drive shaft
going to the rotor you know there's a few
places that are really vulnerable especially
if you hit the pilot there were some dudes
that were that were shot down that got some
some pilots that got held as prisoners right
yes yes and you parade them through the street
of the latino guy yeah there was uh several
of them most of them were uh fighter jet jockeys
because you know they're they're the ones
that got shot down they saw him coming down
uh not many people survived helicopter crashes
you know as much it's a shorter time to get
to the ground right yeah you fall out of a
plane you've got you don't have parachutes
right parachutes there's not one parachute
on a helicopter no damn but i think when you
hit i might bring my own like what's up with
that backpack i'm like no i just have a backpack
it comes out
armor plating and flak jackets right and i
never wore it you know because you thought
you sat on them i sat uh did you ever let
me ask you this did you wear it because you
couldn't button it or because
no i don't have an extension
seat belt i've got your extender for the you
know they're coming from below they're not
going to know i think it's better to sit on
them up there it goes through the helicopter
in your ass exactly and you're [ __ ] nuts
in your [ __ ] nuts god forbid why would you
want to live if that happened did you ever
see someone get shot in a helicopter next
year or near you i my gunner got shot he took
one in the back but he would he live yeah
he got sent back to the united states i i'm
i'm assuming i used to work during the day
in northridge at uh that place telling ir
whatever the [ __ ] that was um there was
a guy named dennis stapp s-t-a-p-p and he
was kind of short guy with a beard and he
walked you know little thing but just a roly-poly
type dude and then we were talking about him
and they said you know dennis was in vietnam
and i said dennis was in vietnam yeah he was
a tail gunner on a helicopter so we used to
go to lunch and walking over and uh i said
hey man you're in vietnam he goes yeah i was
a tail gunner so what is that i shot you know
cleared the roads we want to shot anything
that moved you know the the tanks were going
down there and we had to clear the way i said
you shoot kids he goes maybe i just shot wherever
protect either them or me right i said you
never had any nightmares or anything he goes
no i was doing my job i was just going right
throughout my wow that's what i was paid to
do it's gonna be me or them it's not gonna
be me the only nightmares i've ever had about
that that place is i'm stealing a helicopter
is what is it stealing stealing hill i wanted
to fly so badly i learned how to fly when
i was there oh wow but i wanted to fly so
bad i'd always in in mine i'm always stealing
a helicopter i'm getting a base and i'm stealing
him i'm starting up and i'm taking off that's
your dream all of you would you dream still
today about yeah yeah i still dream let's
get you a [ __ ] helicopter let's go steal
one i love it yeah butterflies when i worked
homicide we had our murder scenes i would
always go up in the bird and take my own pictures
you know it's like bird does bird fly helicopters
no no no no oh yeah yeah he's just about to
take like uh some right before covert and
then and then he's been studying but then
he had to put it off but yeah he's very very
into it he's he's the kind of guy that's going
to get it and then buy his own fleet of helicopters
you know yeah because he's he's so into it
for a long time he was talking about how much
he loved it and then yeah he was going to
take a final exam to fly independently and
covet hit yeah because i i don't it was it's
a ton of hours i remember he told me one time
it's an insane amount of stuff you have to
do to get approved that was one of the reasons
i really wanted to be a deputy only because
they took their pilots from within the rank
and file they wanted to have their pilots
they wanted to bring them in and they were
already indoctrinated you know into law enforcement
work and i ended up going as my career went
on my dream was eventually to get the homicide
bureau i didn't make it i didn't get the arrow
bureau i wanted to go to homicide bureau a
good buddy of mine went through the academy
together were patrol together he went to aero
bureau and he had been a marine corps fighter
pilot and so he's over at arrow bureau and
he flies a helicopter flies fixed wing and
one time he had to fly me up to san jose on
a case and it's just him and i ain't playing
the fix wing and he says hey kill he says
you want to take off we're flying out of long
beach do you want to take off and i said yeah
so there it is man pulled back i got it pulled
up and we're flying and i'm god this is the
greatest [ __ ] feeling i'm up and away so
i said okay you got it and he took it back
and i said you know god damn it there's only
one job i would leave homicide bureau for
i said not for arrow to become a pilot oh
[ __ ] i didn't know that never got it yeah
and he says you know there's only one job
i'd leave arrow bureau for and that's the
lateral over to homicide bureau and he says
unfortunately for the both of us he says i'm
not a good investigator and you're even worse
as a pilot so we better just keep our [ __
] yeah where you are yeah were you into are
you into crime like a lot of people are in
the car you know what's so funny is i i my
i have cops and firefighters all in my family
because i'm an irish you know trash bag from
chicago so it's like your home that's all
your whole family is cops and firefighters
but i i never liked to hear about it because
then i thought then i then i would know someone
that was going to get hurt i would always
every time i heard about like cops getting
shot and stuff like that i always gave me
the [ __ ] creeps because i thought about
my family and then i was like man what if
it's somebody i know because i knew too we
know too many cops so i always got scared
about hearing homicides who's going to take
a shot what criminals going to take a shot
at a police officer because if you're a criminal
you know today i shoot a [ __ ] cop i'm i'm
and they get me there today they do it today
they don't have it today
they don't give a [ __ ] i mean two chicago
cops just got killed and one of them got shot
with their own gun they went out on a domestic
dispute call i think it was something about
a dog or something and it was just the news
it was [ __ ] tragic and they went in there
to investigate i think it was a domestic call
i might be wrong but whatever the case and
uh you know whatever why are those the the
most frightening ones the domestic because
you got a guy that's irrational they're fighting
he's all popped down you don't know what he's
on yeah you go to hook him and then you got
to worry about the wife jumping on your back
because she really didn't want him to go because
that's the breadwinner of the family and i
love him and yeah they call them they call
the cops to and then they want to hurt the
cops when they get there because they're afraid
they're going to lose and and plus it's tough
because you don't know what's going through
his mind yeah i ain't going back to the joint
i ain't doing this right this is he under
the influence it's a tough world and with
everybody looking at you today it's a tough
tell me tell me this is this is true i saw
this the other day on the internet there was
a video compilation of cops patrol cops when
they pulled people over they touched the back
of the car have you ever seen this do you
know what this is for have you ever heard
of this or seen this like leave a thumb print
yeah i never knew that so i there's a video
a bunch of cops when they patrol and they
pull people over they put their hand on the
trunk which is wild because i remember being
pulled over and i he tapped my trunk twice
wow and i was like why why i was like why
did you just touch a trunk he rolled right
through the question but that was what it
said online was to leave fingerprints in case
something happened i just you know never heard
of that no see cops are 38 38 years but in
hindsight the way things are now maybe that's
why not a bad move like the yeah yeah so you
heard of it too right they leave yeah i've
never heard of that i don't know how just
in case some [ __ ] goes wrong look it's probably
just something that if that's not true it
sounds too you know it's like yeah it sounds
too true that you're like it is true to me
it's true sounds like something they ought
to be training the academy yeah serious business
sure because then you find the car and you
go to the thing and exactly you know you gotta
you can see it sometimes yeah my wife is into
all that stuff that like murder mystery and
all that [ __ ] you like that i can't i can't
do it man see i don't have but you know i
don't like any of it yeah i mean i think you
were too close to it now maybe i just think
about it yeah chicago was like not it's a
it was just it's just it's just i didn't like
the stories because i was like is that gonna
be someone i know but she loves that shirt
it is it's gotten way worse now cops were
not so mario the guy that had the place on
uh sunset you know he had the roxy and the
other place right next door uh the rainbow
the rainbow who's that mario mario i can't
remember his last it was an italian and they
just opened one about 10 years ago over in
vegas but then he died uh but he had the ones
right there he's an old chicago cop as the
story goes he was a money man for the judge
and got all that money that he had left over
came over here and turned it into a legitimate
business and he was from chicago michael mann
when he made the movie heat yeah michael mann's
from chicago and he had a captain out here
from chicago and they asked me if i'd help
him out doing interviews you know uh teaching
pacino and these guys you know how to do some
interviews and i told michael mann i said
i can't do it with this guy i mean this guy's
from chicago they put their hands on people
we don't do that [ __ ] out here and he said
i just go out there and do it so we're doing
this interview and he brought with him a buddy
from chicago who's an old chicago wise guy
and he's sitting there and i'm talking about
i say hey what's your name bill bill do you
have a last name yeah what's your last name
smith do you have middle name yeah and he's
just making everything hard and i'm starting
to get a kcs i'm saying look i ain't got time
to be [ __ ] around here you know we're gonna
straighten this [ __ ] out just then my beeper
goes off uh my pager we used to use pagers
oh yeah and i had some guy covering an autopsy
for me because all of a sudden this cop the
retired captain reaches over and smacks this
guy right across the [ __ ] chops hard and
i said uh excuse me i'm going to go answer
this page and there's a wall right there and
i answer the [ __ ] page and it's bobby tucson
bobby says hey gil just like you said it was
a through and through the head you know no
big and then he could hear this guy screaming
and he said what's that where you at give
me the dress where are you at we're rolling
and i said no no i'm on a movie said it's
okay bobby what this captain has done is he's
reached out he's got a handful of the guys
nuts and he says you have something we want
and i've got something you want oh my god
and then the guy he asks him another question
and he squeezes more and the guy blood curdling
scream and tucson's saying god damn it gil
give me an address we'll roll anybody i'm
saying no no and then michael mann finally
hear michael man saying all right cut cut
okay that was good that was i said you see
just the movie said bobby it's it's okay but
he's grabbing this dude's nuts from yeah boys
no thanks there was an actor in that movie
i don't want to say who it is because i don't
even give permission but he told me that he
used to be used to do strong armed robberies
then he turned into an actor and they shot
at bob big boy on on riverside and he was
in there shooting the movie and he was looking
around and he put his head down he goes i
think i [ __ ] robbed this place and he goes
i wonder if they [ __ ] if the managers or
people here are gonna [ __ ] i know that i
know who you're talking about yeah and i know
you're talking about and i we interviewed
him he said hey [ __ ] he said yeah yeah he's
on it man he's like can i get you guys anything
nothing no no we're good okay i'm looking
at this guy and i'm talking and i'm saying
now look at me look at me do i have a tattoo
of a pee on my forehead and he said no i says
because i'm not a pendejo i said now [ __
] you better start and this guy's breaking
out in the sweat and michael mann finally
said okay cut cut excellent excellent and
he comes up to me like man [ __ ] sweating
yeah great job right he says i haven't been
swimming like that man that was like the real
thing i haven't been sweated like that in
a long time you know and pacino comes gail
that was [ __ ] great you do great ass no
this is a [ __ ] living for me brother yeah
that was the reality yeah yeah the same the
same acting this was the real deal so i remember
when you said i know who you got to be talking
about now you never got shot at did you as
a cop or yeah i guys and by another cop by
his own and he just [ __ ] he happened to
just miss him yeah he's trying to hit him
uh it was just no controversy short version
he thought we were bad guys we were playing
clothes he thought we were bad guys and we
had guns out and so he was telling us thankfully
he's a bad shot huh thankfully you know he
was saying drop your guns i'm saying is he
talking to us
and his partner who knew who we were said
it's okay they're cops because i don't know
who they are drop your guns and he yells back
he says hey they're sheriffs because i don't
know who they are drop your boom and he fired
holy [ __ ] and i said holy [ __ ] i said
a lot more than holy [ __ ] did you shoot
back no i'm shooting right back like an elephant
that's why i can't be a cop shoot until i
get you i had already thrown my gun on the
ground but like an elephant i jumped over
the car got on the other side my partner who
was pissed i had another gun strapped to my
leg and i just said it's okay we're back here
if we pull he's going to shoot again i'll
dump him yeah and i knew i i was confident
i could dump him but i didn't have to because
his partner started screaming at me stupid
[ __ ] the gang members that were on the street
like garcinia
you know it was uh it was good stuff and so
he ended up getting fired so then he became
a a sheriff uniform sheriff right yeah patrol
and then he got uh he got asked by another
uh high profile detective uh frank salerno
who caught the hillside strangler yeah yeah
uh bianchi and bono and then he said you want
to be my partner yeah i had been transferred
up to homicide because my specialty was gangs
and after doing that for a couple years then
salerno approached me because i was in homicide
and asked me if i wanted to be his partner
and i was like [ __ ] yes you know that's
creme de la creme right it's top tier so the
nightstalker documentary that's on netflix
yeah it's out right now yeah that a year ago
probably came out a year ago january 14th
and uh that's where i saw it like you know
my publicist was like have you seen that night
talking i've already seen it three times in
that same day right you know and uh gil was
there with with uh frank and then gill was
the first person to say this is the same guy
and everybody else said no no it's two guys
and he goes no [ __ ] that it's the same guy
yeah and and they you would when he left the
room they'd go that guy's [ __ ] full of [ __
] man there's not one guy doing this [ __
] two guys what did they think it was just
two is just two they thought there's no way
one dude could have done all that everything
done when you investigate anything and anything
you do even in comedy everything is predicated
on criminal history with this work but it
won't work well nobody in criminal history
had been documented doing what i was alleging
he was doing you know pedophiles stick to
stick the kids yeah either girls or boys this
guy was doing both he was in his manners of
killing it was guns knives shot foot striking
manual ligature strangulation he just crossed
all the lines but there were certain things
that were there
that i could see was one man and the other
guys were saying you're full of [ __ ] you're
punk trying to make a name of yours we talked
about this before it's funny that the dude
angelo i play golf with he goes i'm gonna
go back on the podcast where you guys aren't
talking about death or what else did he say
yeah but i'm just interested i used to work
at northridge in the in the mid 80s when he
was on his [ __ ] tear and the thing was you
know there was no internet on this [ __ ] you
radio and tv but you knew he was out there
and he would hit in northridge and then when
you got out of work everybody just got the
[ __ ] back to their house but there was like
a [ __ ] feeling in the valley of this dude
and the fear that he's everywhere and he would
[ __ ] deliver i'd be like this dude is out
there you think he'd be like no you know they're
[ __ ] on me he would [ __ ] hit wow that's
so creepy people expected him to hit and he
would hit what was his number what did his
number end up being he ended up killing 14
people here that we're aware of we dropped
one in the interest of justice he says he
was good for four more that we weren't aware
of we looked at actually eight more but there
wasn't enough physical evidence to go ahead
and link them so if we didn't have enough
where we knew we'd get a conviction we didn't
we wouldn't mess with it because we didn't
find anymore huh yeah we didn't want somebody
to say we didn't want to lose a couple of
cases and sway the jurors hey maybe if they
were wrong on these maybe they'd be wrong
over here so unless it was a solid case we
didn't take it he told me that after in custody
about seven years he'd be willing to talk
openly about the other ones that we weren't
aware of and then he got pissed off and he
didn't want to talk to him anymore why he
just because he got married when he was in
custody and so the news media how does that
happen this [ __ ] loves this dude they get
a lot right that you've got a lot of a lot
of women on it and they always do that like
legit women he had some good looking women
following him one day it's like bundy same
thing right yeah women tell me about the the
the ladies that work there ladies in court
one day we had a lot of visitors coming to
court they just want to see what was going
on two ladies dressed to the tens they were
attorneys no doubt little briefcases they
come in they sit down there and they're gorgeous
both of them very business-like richard would
walk into the courtroom and every time we
walked in he'd scan the ladies see who we
wanted to look at on the way out take his
time and so now it's time i get a phone call
they call me up to the bailiff i go up i'm
talking on the phone and i'm looking and it's
time for richard to walk out now he goes back
and he locks eyes with the two broads that
had walked in two ladies had walked and one
of them sitting right on a corner and he looks
and smiles at her she looks at him blows him
a kiss and opens up her legs
and i just couldn't believe it i told i went
back i told my partner [ __ ] arrest me
you know it was just incredible he did have
uh what does this say about beautiful women
and and he marries they're crazy like bad
guys and they married an ugly one too did
he yeah she was ugly and and he got pissed
off because the news media came to me and
you know what do you think about this and
i said it was i thought it was a mockery of
the criminal justice system he wasn't in in
there for rehab he was in their sense of death
yeah and why uh do we have to do anything
and it was a mockery of the sacrament of marriage
because his marriage would never be consummated
right you know so it just made it all worthless
and so do they have rights like that in prison
where you where you can get married and you
can have visitors or you can have visitors
doesn't depend on your level of crime right
you can't have conjugal visits on death row
but it depends on your level right doesn't
it you have to get approved by the judge to
get a controversial visit right it's not standard
is it you you can't my understanding i i won't
say for sure my understanding inmates on death
row cannot have conjugal businesses right
other inmates can have kind of they [ __ ] them
in the shower they've catches that's like
part of the that's part of that's part of
the extras that's a conjugal surprise that's
so surprising that soapy surprise yeah and
and richard uh the way they visited over there
you know it's kind of out in the open everybody
came out to visit the same spot and the other
inmates i was told that they hated they all
wanted him dead because when if he was out
there on a visit and somebody else came by
to visit they had their wives or anybody else
he would take his whacker out and start playing
with himself expose himself to the other visitors
yeah sounds like they hated him they want
to kill him wow damn it's not like something
there's no rules right no i miss prison yeah
i mean what are you going to do today i'm
not here to make friends what did they say
that uh that had to jerk off on my friends
yeah they're the the the wolf
lyle and uh um eric eric uh menendez menendez
were at uh were they were they stated county
jail no yeah they were in county jail before
they got convicted and that they were talking
to the lawyers that richard ramirez walked
by and they both were like wait those are
the kids they killed their parents
sean penn was in the in the jail right across
the hallway from richard wow i don't know
what shot people think that drinking and driving
about abuse yeah it wasn't long it wasn't
there for long it was just in there for a
few days but they were right right along and
so richard wanted to contact him sean my understanding
didn't want to have anything to do with richard
i drove by that house when i first moved to
l.a you know in beverly hills yeah it's your
wife with you she said let's go it's not like
canada or something it's not a major road
in beverly hills i don't remember but you
could still drive by the house but the house
is still there and i was thinking about that
like we're talking to this on my podcast about
living in your house being haunted
and do they have to tell you or not i think
there's something like the next resident they
have to tell but after that i don't think
they don't ownership is different than our
apartment rentals they have to tell you stuff
they have to do with homes they have to do
with homes here too yeah well if somebody
died in the house they have to tell you yeah
but from way back some imagine i showed you
all the stuff on my phone right there my landlord
my first landlord in west hollywood this old
little italian lady west hollywood i was living
in west hollywood and she's one of the first
things she's like are you gay and i was like
no i'm not gay and she's like oh thank god
and i was like you know there's west hollywood
everybody's gay i was like you're in the wrong
business if you this is where you have your
building and she said the the with the man
who was in this he or he died before he you
come here i was like oh [ __ ] oh that's terrible
she goes of aids but you know he was gay and
i was like oh okay the way she
homophobic landlord in the middle of west
hollywood i was like what are you doing in
this neighborhood yeah yeah i was like you're
in the wrong spot sell the building if you
don't like i tell you what after listening
to the podcast and i've heard his stories
and i've been in his house yeah but after
listening that all the man it starts sinking
in man i could never i don't care how drunk
i got i could never spend the night in this
house yeah i'd hey george just let me sleep
outside the front door let me tell you we'll
be on the porch we cleared them pretty much
all out and the lady said that there was a
couple of evil like the poltergeists are the
ones that like you told me not to call anybody
i would call people and they would they would
hear noises and stuff and she said don't call
anybody anymore but that knocking the lie
i was so loud
you think now it's gone you think it's okay
it's pretty much gone but a couple of nights
you know because the floor is old you know
but i'm a light sleeper so i'll be sleeping
and then you'll hear like like like a step
one step and you're like [ __ ] so whoever
whatever spirit that is you can't see but
has enough respect for me to only take one
step it's not going yeah that's it's a trip
man it's a trip to live in that house do you
ever think they're [ __ ] with you like when
they do one step do you ever think like a
a spirit knows that one step is more scarier
that's what i mean i'd be [ __ ] with people
so much if i was a spirit i wouldn't run through
the house i would pull on one thing every
like few days just the one that the one that
really got me was when when my daughter mayan
said you know there's a poltergeist app on
tick tock and i said there is and then i did
it in the room and something showed up in
front of the screen me and then it disappeared
i'm like holy [ __ ] i'm out like what the
[ __ ] is that there's no way i could do both
i couldn't hold it like this and then run
my own hand over it like and i was like it
took me years to get over the [ __ ] yorona
oh now you're gonna lay this [ __ ] on me
yeah yeah forget about it you got to go to
his house go to his house and go check it
out and and he's got a painting he's got some
demonic painting on your wall he said get
rid of that [ __ ] thing that's what bringing
them all together talk which one was that
one the one that's uh not the one that's the
car the cops shooting they said it looks like
an officer involved shooting right yeah it
is yeah the one on the other side on us on
the north oh that's that's carlos armanis
man that's that's like the the chicano painter
what is it an image of um a [ __ ] devil you
know what yeah that guy was a chicano guy
east la big cheech was the guy who turned
me on to him you know because cheech was an
art collector and and he i think he knew carlos
and uh listen when you're married and you
have a show on tv uh money is no object so
ann got me a smaller painting and i got the
big one that's hanging there i got a divorce
and i said how much was that she goes you
don't want to know yeah i don't want to know
right now [ __ ] but when we get divorced
yeah i want to know and there was a i go what's
that it was it was a french like a sh she
goes that hung in a chateau in the 1500s in
paris and i said you know what i'm going to
tell you before i even ask you i don't want
to go home about that yeah no they shipped
it or it was in the chateau oh in the 1500s
is it any of these i just looked up some of
this it is as a matter of fact um as a matter
of fact that painting was probably it's not
in there okay 250 000 then it's probably worth
a million now jesus christ and uh it was his
favorite painting and anne asked his widow
what what she would possibly sell and i believe
uh she sold that painting george didn't know
until it was up on the wall this is this is
how much money ann spent it you know god bless
the [ __ ] the guys that worked on my house
were from england they listened to books on
tape you all know when the [ __ ] expensive
the guys out hiring listen to mexican music
yeah yeah yeah they're a little boombox yeah
they're listening to books on tape airpods
in there yeah they're doing they're doing
venetian blasters i miss that [ __ ] [ __
] books on tape what's the most expensive
thing that you've bought or that's been bought
by you unknowingly is it art like that a quarter
of a million is heavy for ours
when we met i wasn't you know i was a young
comedian struggling i remember there was a
store called address on wilshire and i bought
a die a sapphire and two small settings as
the engagement ring and oh 93 and 12 years
later a guy came with a suitcase with a security
guard and she bought a diamond that was maybe
400 000. holy [ __ ] bought a condo to wear
around that's the wildest [ __ ] and with
that divorce she said [ __ ] him and she took
it out and used it now to have helicopters
land from vietnam
and you know it's one of those where it's
400 at one time but she goes okay mr porsche
mr lakeside mr pebble b oh okay all right
all right we're keeping a tally now yeah but
those are active things uh stone that's so
wild to me i only i only i i always understand
indulging with money on things that you really
really get to use i never i never criticize
because i'm always like if you're going to
use it it's expensive it's fun but man a stone
is so wild to me i saw a girl last night at
the laker game that walked onto the floor
it was like four four rappers or you know
yeah and these dudes i mean the amount of
chains and [ __ ] but the one girl that was
trailing all these dudes in my life i've never
seen i mean it was i mean no [ __ ] was a
silver dollar the size the diamond was a silver
dollar that's how big it was on her hand and
i was like god damn it have been a million
or two right in a in a stone and what but
it's never go it's you can't do anything you
can't sell you're not gonna get your money
back you can get robbed is all you can get
i don't even think like that i can't you're
talking big ass old guys you're talking a
million dollar penny so so i can't even afford
to go to the [ __ ] laker games get him to
the laker game man wear watches and stuff
growing up do you have a chain no you know
what you know it's funny well yeah i had a
chain when i was young and then then when
i got older i just i never wore jewelry and
my dad never wore a lot of jewelry either
he like actually comes from a thing where
you know like you see somebody like your dad
didn't do it maybe your brother didn't do
it somebody didn't do it then you grow up
and you're like nah we our family didn't wear
a lot of we never wore jewelry like i have
watches i have a few nice watches and i never
wear them and it's so silly i don't i don't
even know why i used to love the idea of them
but i'd wear them to like a nice dinner with
my lady on a date and then i sometimes would
wear them to shows but i would feel guilty
you know because it was a nice watch so i'd
feel like man if someone else sees me i'm
on my come up in comedy they're gonna hate
me right if they see me with a nice watch
because you know that comedy is this weird
once you get to a level no one cares anymore
but when you're first getting up and you get
a couple bucks and i bought a watch for my
first sitcom money because i was proud i was
like man i wants one thing nice i was living
in a shitty little apartment i had a [ __
] car what were you was that uh 2009 or 10.
okay and how show was it it was called mixology
on abc it was a one season show but it was
my first sitcom and i got my first check and
i was like man i want to watch i want like
one nice watch and i bought it and i was so
scared to wear it to the store but when i
would go on the road i could wear it when
i left l.a i would wear it because i was like
nobody can judge me i'm gone i'm not in l.a
but when i go to the club with the improv
of the store i was just scared of [ __ ] i
didn't want someone to be like yeah sure this
month you know i because the competition is
so thick in comedy people hate people love
to see you on the come up but they hate to
see it happening you know they're proud of
you but they don't want to watch you do it
they don't want to know you have a little
bit of money what happened oh god did it fall
off yeah that's right somehow somehow they
would they don't want to see you they want
that like every comic i think this is in most
industries i mean most peers you want your
friends to rise in whatever ranks it is but
there's a degree of their rise where they're
like [ __ ] that guy everyone does that it's
just it's uh it's hard to get away from i
don't know for some reason to pull you down
yes they're crabs in a bucket yeah
the moment you see someone get too too famous
in society we want to shoot them out of the
sky you love to boost them up and then when
they get too big they you want to shoot them
down and you're a stranger think when your
friends do it it's weird when someone you
know kind of hates on you because you've got
something that's what's wild that's it so
yeah because i'll say this because um you
know i didn't we don't have any more advantages
than anybody else like you're it's just your
work like you know i was i was uh i started
in 79 arsenio was in 89 i started doing arsenio's
and then he stopped at 95 so 95 and 99 were
my darkest years when i was drinking and i
was going nowhere and i remember thinking
man i became the last [ __ ] thing i wanted
to be which is a road comedian and i just
won new year's eve i decided you know i'm
just going to start worrying less about [ __
] everybody else and only worry about myself
i still worry about i used to read people
the [ __ ] empire and my wife would buy it
i was worried about everybody else man it's
like this is this can't be [ __ ] healthy
so 1 98.99 i'm like you know what and it was
and it was almost like drugs getting off drugs
because you'd be like what's that is that
people might oh no no i'm okay no no i don't
want to get not trying to quit you're like
is that the trade and i decided to [ __ ] worry
less about what's going on and worry more
about what's going on with me and it [ __
] that works i can change man yeah you can't
worry about somebody else you [ __ ] bragging
on somebody it's like a negative [ __ ] you're
like you know how you know they can [ __ ] him
but think about how bad social media is now
for people on the right i was just going to
ask if you found it like is it harder now
no because right because he's out he is already
at a point where that do you know what i mean
that that's the way but the youngest guys
in comedy that they have to deal with it constantly
and they used to [ __ ] on tick tock that
aren't bad in 15 seconds yeah yeah like they
can't do anything beyond that but like that
little dude that came in here that's not that
little dude but the dude that does me leon
that motherfucker's got a whole [ __ ] house
in the hills
yeah he i mean he made his he made his thing
doing me he does like impressions of like
women here but you should be able to tax that
yeah
of the other characters he plays when he's
a teacher when he's this when he you know
but he made his his he made a hit doing you
still still do it yeah tick tock tick tock
is the thing that's going i mean that's the
next generation's thing they break they break
music so wait wait say his name again this
kid leo gonzalez leo gonzalez he does me trying
to find my car let's see he's like this is
george lopez trying to find his car there's
a part of it that's flattering though right
isn't it it's nice right it's nice that someone's
doing it all right it's there's a part of
it that's flat i can tell right now he's pissed
off he didn't like it that's a part of it
that's flattering it's got to be but then
i know i'm sure there's a part of it that
you're like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you a little
bit yeah a little bit let's see oh i've seen
this kid
after i delivered a joke yeah but yeah i seen
this dude
he's right you just did it just now yeah just
there you go he did one together because he
was on the pockets like he said they did one
together after we do one together here he's
like doing it uh where leah's doing like i
don't know how old is
this [ __ ]
and he's living a pretty good life you know
what uh uh there's a there's an actress that
used to follow me and uh we went out a couple
times and she doesn't follow him anymore but
she follows him it's like hey i want the [ __
] imitator i want real crap i'll take the
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm the original i'm the one
i want lobster i'll take some yeah give it
an imitation so you get a imitation crap out
of black mirror is like they don't follow
you they follow the person who's famous it's
a trip because as i move closer to the end
and you see the guys coming up in the beginning
it's a whole different oh yeah does it it's
all about let me add does it bother you personally
you've paid your dues both make fun of me
to have a guy to have no not make fun of you
but all these young guys on tick tock they're
getting all this fame and they're getting
money out of it you know without paying their
dues now you know what man anybody who's ever
stepped on a stage has paid if you take one
step and you go up there and you talk for
five minutes like get the [ __ ] out you paid
dues right there because that's an experience
you will never forget and you'll be like hey
tell by that time you did comedy oh we're
at this bar in chicago i went up there trying
to i thought i was going to be funny they
[ __ ] threw [ __ ] at me and it's traumatic
for the rest of your life yeah
it has to exist i mean like this is his that
has to exist as much as the veteran that puts
in 20 years and then pops has to exist it's
that's the balance because these two things
serve as totally different things did you
see uh that show dave yeah yeah that's the
show i did yeah okay it's still going on yeah
we're gonna do another season in june we'll
do our third season here's the thing because
people become like creatures of their shows
like if you watch like maybe succession and
maybe you might not even see dave or or or
i think you might like it i watched it i bought
the first season i won the second season i
think it's great man i mean it's so funny
man is your car are you gay or not gay that's
funny that you say that i joked about it because
i said i said you're not going to let me get
a girl this whole show and he's like we're
going to work on something for the third season
i said because because i it couldn't because
who knows yeah because you guys are friends
but but there's a little bit of like when
guys are friends yeah there's something
it is so funny they throw he throws a lot
of that [ __ ] in there i think he does that
just to [ __ ] with people i think he thinks
that's funny to [ __ ] with people on that
but for me i said in the third season i said
i better get something you better throw me
something right it's too vague man and your
character like uh uh it's funny when they
show you as a kid oh yeah yeah they give you
some of that they show them as a kid and they
give them some of the traits that he had which
i think is [ __ ] wrong too like yeah with
no beard nothing did a little reddish hair
red headquarters and he's talking as a kid
in the lunchroom and you're like oh [ __ ] that's
him because yeah i like when they do i mean
they're gonna i hope the third season the
explores bigger and bigger and bigger because
you know like at some point these shows that
are about the business because it's about
the rap world and the entertainment world
like entourage at some point you don't give
a [ __ ] about the business on the show you
want to see more about the people on the show
which i hope we get more into because the
business side of the show uh people don't
really give a [ __ ] about i think like entourage
was funniest or those shows are the funniest
when the characters have a funny character
story built out that doesn't have to do with
hollywood as much it's more about that outside
world so if we get into that i mean what was
uh brilliant i thought is that you know he's
a rapper he's jewish rapper and they give
him the name and then he's like his girl's
like rap i never heard you rap he's like nah
you know he doesn't want to do it yeah he's
embarrassed you're comfortable doing it and
then he goes in the studio and they you know
they're [ __ ] clowning them and then he does
it and he lights it up [ __ ] brilliant man
that was what yeah that was when we did the
first that was uh yg and um yeah the camera
remember the other dude but yg and a bunch
of dudes you know look no disrespect to them
they're the [ __ ] but they they brought a
whole crew and some of the dudes on the crew
brought real guns to the show and they were
like we can't have that inside this studio
dude and they weren't they weren't coming
out of the set i think they were just people
that wanted to come kick it with him that
were like when they did the studio they oh
my god but it's so funny to think that you're
like yeah man if you want the real deal you're
going to get the real d the real deal you
know i mean there's no facade with a lot of
these guys that's that is what it is and we
shot a lot of time i mean we shot uh a ton
of that show in south la so if we ever did
anything with guys that were affiliated it
was real i mean it was like there was no there
this weird line of hollywood that people that
work in hollywood that are affiliated do you
know what i mean like snoop is affiliated
but he works in hollywood yeah and it's this
weird balance but he knows guys that will
still come real and i mean there's that weird
line man so when i was doing uh the talk show
like 2009-10 audrey plaza and i on a saturday
there was a there was a like a hood tour almost
like a tmz tour of hollywood but it was hood
it was gang i was a gang affiliated tour south
central so they presented it to me i said
let's do it the guy came on saturday we got
in there audrey aubry and i and then i had
a little white girl assistant and we're in
there and the guy saying you know up here
where snoop did this they're getting like
the ice cube over here and that's like but
it's all about and we go to the jungle where
they shot in that cul-de-sac where denzel
washington's [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so king
kong king kong [ __ ] training so aubry did
that scene in the cul-de-sac george come back
cause i left it she's like you [ __ ] i will
have you like going off on the street and
we get out and they had to ask those dudes
that we could be on the street correct and
they knew me that respect i have respect for
them and then a little white girl goes as
her ad-lib can george get a cheetah up in
this [ __ ] and these dudes went [ __ ] george
and like i was like we're just messing around
but when he said [ __ ] george yeah yeah that
wasn't that was that was real oh yeah yeah
yeah i'd have been like let's go we gotta
go we gotta go we haven't gotten over there
like what happened right there oh this dude
got capped uh like what's today's sunday uh
saturday's friday yeah you're like [ __ ] you
have to check in when you know that you know
that you know that area they don't [ __ ] around
man when be real was sitting right there and
be real came in here and be reals from here
and i always thought lapd was the people he
had to look out for and he's like oh hell
no man sheriff would come and [ __ ] roust
you you lied to a sheriff i could beat your
ass man if you don't lie to a shirt because
you lied to lapd but you don't lie to a sheriff
and uh they had a little respect for the sheriffs
i sat right there i was like no [ __ ] like
i didn't know i was like what the you guys
you guys don't like each other the sheriff
and i like don't they don't oh no no that's
that's friendly rivalry that's all it is up
on the top level before we have what's going
on but up at the top level there was always
you know bumping heads yeah when we did the
night stalker case first thing we did with
our counterparts from lapd we said let's we
just sat down and said okay we don't give
a [ __ ] what they say up on top we keep nothing
from each other we work the case we share
information and it was the best operation
we've ever had okay so check this out so when
richard ramirez was out there these dudes
like were in jeopardy because you know you
don't know if that [ __ ] is going to come
and try to take you know try to take somebody
in your family yeah he knows where you live
so his so gil's family left like he's like
hey you guys got to get out of here all this
[ __ ] is going on because it's not safe here
so gil's at his house in the middle of the
night and he hears a noise and he gets up
and he gets his gun he's got his he's got
his gun and he's he's got his back against
the wall because that's how they do it and
in the middle of the night his phone rings
and i said how [ __ ] high did you jump is
that scared off damn [ __ ] out of me man
3 30 in the morning i'll never forget imagine
that like you're you hear something and you're
like this and you're looking around the phone
rings i'm just gonna start shooting at the
phone channel five john wayne there was a
movie he spoke hero who was that who who called
you do you think it was it was the office
calling me telling me to call linda arthur
my good friend who was on the documentary
yeah she was a deputy she lived right across
from sophie dickman who was one of our victims
she was on july the 7th and she had been raped
she had been burglarized she had been robbed
then she drugged she was handcuffed to the
bed drug her bed at the window and started
yelling mrs arthur or mrs arthur because my
friend linda arthur who was a deputy lived
right across from her linda's husband had
just been murdered june 1st and this is july
7th she called and she was working on crime
lab at the time she'd been out on some of
the murder scenes with me she was my friend
i'd gone through the academy with her husband
they called me up and they said call into
arthur at home here's her number yeah and
she calls this all in your neighborhood no
this was i was living at that time in roland
heights in monterey park and they just said
she says gil i think you got to come down
here lady cross street just got robbed and
raped and i think it's part of what you're
working on it was just this [ __ ] worked
alone yes and uh he was mostly when i was
it mostly in the valley no it was all over
it was everywhere everywhere when i woke up
exactly you know because uh homicide cops
nurses first thing they do something happens
what time is it yeah because you always want
to document everything when i jump i look
3 30 in the morning i get back in bed and
i'm saying what the [ __ ] is he doing right
now this is [ __ ] with me you know it's really
i can't call the cops because if i clear nobody's
here they're gonna think i'm nuts right you
know but subconsciously i just thought somebody
was in my house so i cleared my house get
back in bit and now you know i gotta call
up over there and so i gotta go check it out
but i'm sitting there what the [ __ ] is going
on sophie dickman will say at 3 30 in the
morning he started sodomizing her she looked
at the clock because she was a nurse she says
3 30 in the morning he was right there in
the hood yeah so it was right by him it was
uh it was kind of tough it was just a crazy
eye that's nuts man just to think about it
and also your mind's gonna play some tricks
on you too and like they're it's not gonna
help because you're overthinking it anyway
oh that's all i want if you're looking for
it it's gonna be there type of thing when
the documentary finally dropped i apologize
to my wife because
the job was is i thought your job is the house
and the kids my job is to find this killer
and so i paid no attention to her and the
kids and after watching the documentary i
apologized to her because i said i'd never
thought of and i hadn't factored in the fear
factor i wasn't there to protect you she was
there all by herself she was crying it was
a tough time so i asked for forgiveness you
know and she was kind enough to say okay it's
all right she gave it to you yeah that's that's
wild man i still tell her we got the wrong
guy once once here i tell her we got the wrong
guy ever move out again
and that was over there at that cecil hotel
downtown oh yeah crazy ass hotel that they're
trying to stay up they change their name stay
on main oh yeah this is where the girls it
still says cecil on the side yeah they remodeled
it they've they've done a bunch of it's a
beautiful hotel inside but but it's i'm gonna
take my wife there next week thank you yeah
they got good rates right now man thank you
man like you go in the room and they're i
mean it's ominous driving by it you can never
scratch that off that label is going to be
there no matter how what you do to it even
alexandria over there down down there too
because purple rain they shot in minneapolis
but they shot some of it on in downtown l.a
is that right alexandria that's right you
and momo said yeah there's some noises down
there momo's talking about the alexander one
yeah momo's got uh um paranormal stuff see
you get into that so deep i i like it i actually
asked um aj barrero who's a who's uh i'm sure
he said okay um
you have aj aj gonna come down just a single
text that says definitely haunted definitely
haunted he'll come in here and say this place
is on this place that's what we'll say okay
so i found this picture of bob saget and me
and whoopi and john oliver i saw that you
posted it and let me show you man that's sad
yeah let me show you a legend that was awesome
i didn't know who john oliver was though
uh you know who he is now though look at this
no i just saw it this morning uh last week
tonight on each other it's like uh yeah it's
why i mean it's a weekly nightly sort of show
kind of daily
look at the exposure of this picture it's
half and light it happened oh dude you know
what's really tragic about about the bob thing
other than that and i can have everything
the real tragic thing is uh his post yesterday
after doing shows was so beautiful yeah as
a guy who's been doing it since the late 70s
which i met him in 79 to be in 2022 first
show 2022 and to put those thoughts down yeah
as to how he felt to do his first showing
he was so excited he was like man i did an
hour and a half i couldn't believe it you
know it's like it was like he was feeling
something which is wild because you know if
he was feeling not well he wouldn't have said
anything so what's strange is he must have
been feeling great which is even more strange
to me because you wouldn't tweet out how wonderful
it felt to do your set again if you were like
man i'm not feeling right the set wasn't good
i'm a little off do you know what i mean i
don't say i go into disappearance mode when
i'm having a if when it's tough on the road
or long gigs or the shows are okay you don't
say [ __ ] online he must have had he must
have been vibing and then i don't know who
knows we'll find out what happens later but
it's a bummer this is shitty man and i didn't
know the dude that's why i didn't really kind
of say anything about him publicly because
i don't know him on a personal level but
well man we always it's funny how we always
found you know he was always because he would
be like what do you see right here he's like
uh
ah yeah i want to spoon you like two men you
know yeah yeah yeah i mean that's bob back
he said give me let's get back to a bunk bed
or something like that yeah yeah let's go
to bunk bed and we'll you know we'll get better
i mean
man you know like you i didn't know the man
i've seen him and now yeah here we did his
podcast i really felt bad for george uh cedric
was very vocal and you know he he put some
some people very high profile comedians and
people in the business were saying uh nice
stuff about him so i was more concerned my
my feelings are certainly with his family
and yeah i didn't know him personally but
my feelings were with george with cedric all
these other people that really were touched
because it's close to the loss of a friend
yeah yeah it is wild when it's he became one
of those dudes man like that would always
be like how are you like you know you're good
man like he was worried about i drank too
much and then he's worried that i was alone
like he was trying to find somebody for me
and i said and he was alone and then he met
somebody and we talked about that how he didn't
think he was going to get married again and
how he he just didn't want to be alone for
the rest of his life and that he met somebody
and they were in love man it's like you know
whatever whatever is in charge of whatever's
going on with us it it could take you at your
lowest point or it can take you when you're
in a great point in your life oh no absolutely
and you're like which is better honestly i
don't probably the highest point maybe i don't
want to go when i'm low and then you know
like
he was more concerned about me last week than
i was about myself like he was like are you
all right you know and like that's pretty
[ __ ] amazing man yeah those those people
are are worth their weight in gold the ones
who like ask you how you're doing they'll
be like but no how are you doing yeah he's
a great one yeah man and forever like he's
been around like betty while you say hey on
the view that i why is betty white so important
too because she's been around my whole life
yeah like you watch password in the summer
with your friends and i [ __ ] laughing and
[ __ ] and bob too man like i went to the
comedy store in 1979 and [ __ ] bob was one
of the first dudes i met and he was cool i
mean like [ __ ] guy was good back then did
then he get you know in the 80s and he got
[ __ ] america's funniest home bidders and
then when i came up he would see like hey
it's like it's like it's almost like you know
if you're in the if you're in the like donnie
bros go like you're on the [ __ ] bottom you're
chipping [ __ ] parking meters and then you
do whatever you make it up and you get made
like you're you're with those dudes man like
when i met dennis miller like the first time
he shook my hand he goes hey welcome welcome
aboard like he's like you know you [ __ ] made
it up like welcome aboard man you're one of
us yeah and you're like you're [ __ ] right
i want it you know that's what happens yeah
yeah he was on for a while he was on for a
long time i mean he's been around he [ __
] left funny his home videos yeah like left
and everybody thought he was clean
it was funny for me when i used to go to the
lab factory and people couldn't believe the
[ __ ] he would say you talk about [ __ ] the
olsen twins and it was the funny they couldn't
wrap their head around they were like this
isn't the funniest videos guy is it yeah they
would come to me and they go hey man you know
that dude for the funniest one what's his
name bob and sag i said yeah and he's like
i saw him that's [ __ ] i said yes yeah the
dirt was he funny goes in the beginning no
and then yes it's like yeah but of course
like a shock yeah they can't believe it he
had earned his [ __ ] stripes man like he'd
been doing it a long time that long and then
we talked about he would do my guitar gently
weeps like back in the day and he turned the
thing he had a wire to type on the in the
podcast and he would do oh my and the guitar
would water would come out of the guitar and
i said i remember you he goes i [ __ ] still
do it in that picture that he was in uh orlando
the guitars on the uh he was doing it oh yeah
i gotta still do it wow and i said how did
you do that man he goes i had like some bladder
on my on my stomach and i had a [ __ ] aquarium
tube and when i turned the knob i pushed the
guitar towards it pushed the watch great but
they were killers man those guys killed a
bunch of stuff for him doing stuff at danger
fields back in the day yeah riding was riding
yeah rodney liked him a lot i think he's because
he was really fast i think his style was fast
he would get into that uh that thing where
he'd go and i want to love you but not like
a man as a woman like a man as a man we get
hawaiian shirts we'll get some bunk beds and
we'll get some kfc we'll spend the night like
that that like he'd get that [ __ ] and then
he would get that [ __ ] going yeah and you
didn't know what he was going to say but it
was it was just kind of his cadence you know
yeah rest in peace to that dude man yeah those
are all like hey you know what you went to
vietnam we're warriors in another in that
business where one goes and you feel yeah
you feel it it's wild even if you don't really
like i didn't even know him but it's just
weird to feel it because you know i don't
know it makes you question a lot of [ __ ] because
we're doing it and you i every comic on earth
thinks about passing away on the road in hotels
every comic is like it doesn't matter how
good the tour is how bad the tour is you think
about it you think about being in a hotel
you're in another city you're out you're away
from home or your family and your friends
and you're and i always call you yeah man
it always passes through your mind just another
hotel somewhere you know uh robin harris in
the uh did do the right thing he played a
sweet dick willie those guys that would sit
around in front of me but mike tyson my boy's
got a head like a pit bull like robin harris
was on his way up like on his way up and he
was uh he did uh a house party played the
dad and he's hilarious he used to work at
the bank and i worked in northridge and i
met him somewhere and he's like yo come and
see me at el altorito altorito on wilshire
there was an el torito by by 97.1 klsx over
there and there was an el torito on wednesdays
they did comedy and he worked at the bank
and he went up there and for an hour just
ripped into people and i sat there man he's
like yo young blood you want to go there i
said [ __ ] you man i ain't going up there
and he was he was brilliant man yeah brilliant
he started doing those movies he was in chicago
and they went to go look on look look at him
he had a show and like greg gerald passed
away in the hotel room another hotel i said
you stay i used to stay in that hotel when
you go do stress factory you stay in that
same hotel i thought about that all the time
that's those dismal things that you're like
man man the road is so weird you know what
man because we all touch each other in a weird
way you all have touched a comic and even
if you've never met you know you know them
somehow you've connected somewhere there was
a dude named um kane lopez who was like a
young young guy and uh i had found out that
he was sick i didn't know him but i'd seen
him up in sacramento but brian kellen knew
him and i said hey man you know cain lopez
and he goes yeah i said i heard he's not doing
very well man so i think when we land on sunday
in burbank you should go see him and i went
to go see him too i'd never met him and i
went in there and he surprised to see me his
dad was there i paid for his funeral man because
they didn't have the money and i thought we're
soldiers and that's what yes so god bless
you yeah man i mean i'm worried now uh which
is what we should do you know we should yeah
you got to help our yeah yeah my my good buddy
that i've talked to you about before the one
he's got stage forge can't stay for uh cancer
lung but he's he's a crazy guy and he's funny
so a great great great outlook on life you
know the the doctor said we give you uh we're
not gonna operate we can give you three to
three to ten years he says i'll take six yeah
and then he sits and he says hey i know you're
going through some [ __ ] so hey if things
go wrong with you he says are you gonna be
pissed off will it offend you if i go to your
services and i'm sitting right next to your
wife with my arm around her you know so he's
a great guy when i got to take care of her
you know when i talk to him it's always about
not how he's doing it's how are you doing
yeah i know man always concerned more for
me and if i learned nothing else from my dad
that's what my dad was my dad would he was
dying of cancer and he had lung cancer and
he'd sit there how are you doing with that
i'm not doing too good today forget about
me though how are you how are the kids you
know always concerned for everybody else that's
a great trait it's a noble feeling when you
sit there and say that but you know this business
man can make you like a cop it could desensitize
you to real feelings because there's a part
of you you have to turn off in order to entertain
yeah and then you have your wife and you have
your kids where they don't have that part
but then you have to be able to to co exist
with them sure and not want to go hide which
i always wanted i was always alone anyways
so when i was married i was always upstairs
and you can hide and say like you know it's
part of my process but it's not it's just
you just prefer to be by yourself yeah yeah
yeah there's something about being able to
we get you do have to turn off pieces of you
as a comic so when you have to check back
into reality and feel feelings with other
people it is weird because the way we have
to temper all that stuff because you're just
used to the [ __ ] even if it's like let's
go have breakfast you know sunday at 10 we're
back by two you're like how about two [ __
] all right yeah yeah where oh
yeah because you know you people recognize
you're right you're going for yeah yeah and
that's that's a trip too yeah because all
of a sudden it's like hey are you and then
yeah it's sometimes something it's okay sometimes
and sometimes you're really not in the mood
for it but it you know i'm always gracious
of it i said that one time i was like those
people pay my mortgage man so i'm happy to
see him but also sometimes if you're in a
shitty mood right people expect you to be
happy and engaging all the time there's times
where you wish you could have a tag on that's
like not today it's a shitty day today yeah
just we have shitty days so up in uh in silmar
at the olympia hospital my grandmother was
in the hospital grandma raised me this was
like august of 2009 i was doing my talk i
was getting ready to do my talk show but to
show it syndicated and uh i went in there
and i talked to my grandmother about like
just you know she was in a coma about going
and stuff like that and then she had passed
away and they were going to take her downstairs
and you know that guy said you know there's
nothing you can do and i went downstairs and
they saw me downstairs my grandmother just
died and she raised me and they're like hey
can we take a picture with this ah yeah come
on come on take a picture and and you didn't
say like hey my grandmother just died yeah
oh come on yeah it's all right five or six
or whatever then got in my car i went but
i never thought about saying no because they
don't know but they'll be like [ __ ] that
guy that's weird man it's crazy you're not
allowed to do what they would turn it off
yeah yeah it's strange sometimes that that
it is strange because you're like i get it
they don't know and if you explain it to them
it's going to be even weirder you know that
you're like hey i don't want to do that my
my grandmother's dead yeah they're like yeah
but you're a comedian right you're like yeah
[ __ ] it you're great yeah yeah they think
you're full of [ __ ] that doesn't matter
just hey yeah i didn't work today i didn't
think i was going to see i got my cat got
my kids right here your grandma died all right
yeah yeah so so um uh what's in the future
you doing movies or are you doing i did a
couple of movies i did a couple of netflix
movies i did one with kevin hart which was
great i actually did the remake of that house
party movie there yeah they're putting they're
putting out the like the new generation of
it yeah i did a couple of scenes in that it
was fun but i did a movie with kevin hart
and mark wahlberg that'll come out because
kevin hart does uh dave right there they're
part of he's a pretty brother he's an ep yeah
he's one of heartbeat is one of the nine yeah
that's wild these days every card every card
you're like who's that who's that [ __ ] dudes
in that yeah yeah no it's it's a it's a heavily
pushed show by the train but i like it i like
it i think it really is phenomenal yeah it's
fun it's a good show we're gonna do that again
in june uh those couple of movies will come
out at some point and then i'm touring now
until um april i think and then i'm done in
april i'm going to take a month off i'm going
to europe for a month well first oh first
of all no i'm just going to go i just want
to get out i just want to get away for a while
yeah i want to shoot a special sometime right
before the summer that's the plan would you
do it for net for netflix or whatever i don't
know i think i'm gonna do it on my own oh
yeah i think i'm gonna do it on my own like
i've been talking about it for a long time
um about self-distribution just because you
know i know i'm not that big like how like
louis puts his out and you buy his own but
i think the model is great because you're
like the model is great the money goes to
you you control all the elements no one's
telling you what you can and can't say there's
no like programming ideas they have to slot
you in a way in a month at a time i just don't
want to deal with that stuff i think i don't
know i mean i'm not 100 but i think i'm going
to do that finish up and then we want to get
away for like a month go to europe and just
disappear for a while and then come back and
shoot season three of dave and yeah that'll
be that that's an awesome it's an awesome
show thank you brother yeah and how's it going
in chicago you're gonna be at the yeah i'm
gonna do chicago theater but i'm gonna be
there february 5th when is this out is this
out soon uh this is probably next week monday
all right good so yeah february 5th i'm going
to be there uh at the chicago theater boys
coming back to chicago the hometown show i'm
excited some of the chicago bulls are going
to come which makes me feel like does it have
a theater a few times beautiful it's wild
i did it once with rogan when i used to tour
joe rogan a few times like he would take me
out i did it with him once and i was sitting
back there and the stage manager was like
he said yeah i was like this is incredible
man when it was closed you know and they kick
everyone out and you just are looking at this
empty space he's like you'll do it and i was
like the [ __ ] out of here man i thought
he was being a smartness he's like you'll
do it man i was like i don't know man you
don't know me you don't know if i'm gonna
be able to do it and then cut you know two
and a half years later i'm gonna do it in
uh in 1989 we went to we did ski patrol we
did in utah and then roger rose was from chicago
me and roger paul feig director and steve
heidener went to hang out with roger in chicago
and roger had a buddy larry jacobs that wrote
for letterman letterman was doing a week at
the chicago theater buddy guy jay leno michael
jordan damn and we sat in the chicago theater
and i never thought that i would sell that
place out four times or whatever the [ __
] but it's one of my it's incredible one of
my prizes it means a lot to me to come home
and to go be able to do it i mean it's because
it's beautiful so pretty man the side door
you you walk upstairs there's cement stairs
and you have that nice room over there then
you walk down and you turn and you go it's
100 years old too which is nice it's beautiful
he's showing it to him yeah it's stunning
i haven't seen the inside 100 years old yeah
and it's restored al capone's booth is still
there his booth is uh of the first row of
those those booths see the you know the the
what are they what do they call those
but actually what's wild is the reason that
it's the furthest left the the stage manager
told me is because across the street right
across the street is uh a building that one
of their affiliates owned and it was one of
the only buildings at the time that had an
elevator that could go from street level to
basement level so al could get down and out
into a car and be gone and i said oh if he's
you know if it's from someone in the theater
trying to trying to come get him and he's
like no it's always the cops because the cops
always be like two steps behind him and they
were always chasing him down and stuff so
when he went out for an entertainment night
he'd get away with an hour or two of being
out and then cops would try to come get him
because they know something's going on he's
never seen any play end yeah no yeah he's
always been half a player intermission is
they made it for him he's got to get out of
here that place is haunted oh sure i was uh
doing a meet and greet and then you know you're
meeting people right here i'm saying right
there and i felt somebody go like this and
i went i went right there i go something just
touched my right arm right here and again
the usher goes yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's haunted for sure you can tell
when you go somewhere back to those old theaters
uh man it gives you it gives you so much weird
history there too that it really like you
feel in your chest when you go to the bowels
of them
you'd stay away from that [ __ ] you're gonna
go back no no no you know what [ __ ] around
with it but you feel you feel something in
those rooms they're so old and the thousands
and thousands of performers that have been
through there over the years and it's just
you can't help but feel something you know
the stairs are cement so they're not like
they're tile they're cement so that's immense
cement yeah all the way up down turn right
go back down the stage back up and that room
is in there and you see whoever uh you know
buddy guy you see yeah uh all the members
of whatever band sitting in that room that
you're sitting there like how it's right there
that feels really it feels wild that's the
same way i feel about the store whenever whenever
i go out on stage there's always a moment
on the main room floor that i'm like man the
guys that used to tape specials at the stores
when that main room had that hbo special and
it just it's it's weird to think about that
of all these glad you're doing the chicago
theater congratulations thank you man it's
great to know you man and uh thank you for
doing this appreciate you man did you introduce
him great no we always do that at the end
do it now thanks thanks so much for coming
out he's the greatest previously on the podcast
today andrew santino actor podcaster comedian
golfer yeah golfer yeah we got to go play
i got here yeah let's go i'm in and tune in
to uh his pocket yeah whiskey whiskey ginger
and bad friends me and bobby lee have one
but whiskey ginger is the one where it's just
me george came on and did it bobby lee is
uh we're trying to get him back on here he
is insane just psycho man he got all excited
because he came in is that the first very
first show i did with george i didn't even
know i was doing a podcast i was invited to
meet friends and i came in here and i sat
right there and bobby lee's here and it was
really a fun time for me he's nuts and he
is nuts and he shows him and he said he did
not he started crying literally and then just
picked up his t-shirt and said [ __ ] stop
you made me cry and and he wiped his tears
and today in a message that i got from you
he wants to he said to say hello to the kill
he said bobby said be sure and say hello to
gil and i told jordan i said [ __ ] i pissed
in my pants like a little puppy yeah i mean
he remembered me you know yeah of course it
was fun and bobby's like you know what did
bobby say like hey [ __ ] are you are you
are you gonna make it some [ __ ] i said [ __
] yes finally somebody you know uh how are
you gonna make it oh i'm glad yeah yeah tell
girl i said hi uh you know because out because
i was sick new year's eve [ __ ] and the thing
the thing with that the thing with new year's
eve is i don't have covert but i have a kidney
transplant upper respiratory and dehydration
and that's those are the dangers so so i'm
at home like and and like bob like he's like
ah you know i'm okay so you if you cancel
your [ __ ] [ __ ] because there's shows and
people bought tickets but if you go hey man
i don't feel really good man i don't think
i should do i don't think i should do it and
they'll be like oh this motherfucker's trying
to bail out on new year's eve what you're
not trying to do and then you go and when
i got up there half hour in 20 minutes in
i was sweating you knew this is not good and
uh
i sat down and i got back up andrew i saw
a [ __ ] red [ __ ] streak in front of me
i was like oh the [ __ ] is that and i told
my nurse that he goes yeah you see red right
before you drop yeah you just i was gonna
say i've seen that right before i pass out
yeah you passed out
it's a church not holy spirit thank you brother
i appreciate you man my man this is great
all right thank you hey this is so much fun
thank you man i appreciate it
you